ja also auch ein strukturproblem ich
finde es ist zeit dass wir ein augenmerk
darauf richten wie es um die gleiche
bezahlung steht für frauen innerhalb des
zdfs und das betrifft vor allem betrifft
vor allem die freien mitarbeiterinnen
nämlich hat die ehemalige frontal21
reporterin dörte meyer gerichtlich
bewiesen dass es im zdf immer noch ein
fremdwort ist frauen drei
mitarbeiterinnen gleich zu bezahlen wie
männer sie ist also sieben jahre lang
durch die gerichte gegangen die
arbeitsgerichte bis zum
bundesverfassungsgericht ist am ende
abgeschmettert mit dem wunsch und es hat
das zdf vier jahre lang verweigert
auskunft zu geben darüber was die
privaten recherchiert hatte dass sie
nämlich weniger verdient als ihre
männlichen kollegen
und nun das ganze ein bisschen zu
erläutern es gibt ein entgelt
transparenzgesetz 2017 das besagt dass
eine frau innerhalb eines betriebes
nachfragen darf beim arbeitgeber was
denn die männlichen kollegen
vergleichbarer tätigkeit
verdienen aber es braucht in diesem team
mindestens sechs männliche kollegen die
das gleiche machen was ja nicht in jedem
team der fall ist also dieses gesetz ist
schon mal verbessert und in sich schon
mal nicht ganz rund denn das zdf hat
dann umgekehrt einfach gesagt neues also
in meinem fall zum beispiel habe ich
auch angefragt 2017 es gibt in ihrem
team nicht sechs männliche kollegen also
können wir diesen vergleich nicht machen
und weil sie freie mitarbeiterin sind
haben sie auch kein recht darauf ja und
was sie aber geschafft hat birte meyer
diese frontal21 report daran durch diese
sieben jahre gerichtsweg nicht dass die
gleich viel verdient aber sie hat
geschafft das jetzt mitarbeiterinnen die
frei sind auch ein recht haben diese
auskunft vom zdf zu bekommen auf dieser
ebene wird also im klein klein aber mit
langem gerichts wegen die nerven kosten
die biographien nachhaltig schädigen
wird politik gemacht personalpolitik und
das muss aufhören und deswegen fordere
ich erstmals die führung das zdf auf
ihre strukturen was das angeht
transparent zu machen offenzulegen wie
hier frauen bezahlt werden erstens und
zweitens fordere ich die
mitarbeiterinnen die freien auf nichts
sich zu schauen eine
rechtsschutzversicherung abzuschließen
und dann den weg durch die
arbeitsgerichte zu gehen dann bis sie
endlich gleich bezahlt werden wie männer
in frage die tätigkeit frau sei es
damals ja auch noch zusätzlich als
allein schon der mutter auch das arbeits
kontingent verkürzt worden ja das war
2017 also ich habe 75 arbeits kontingent
gehabt und dann hat man mir gesagt nein
du bekommst es nur noch 55 prozent knapp
deshalb so großen aufruhr geführt auch
innerhalb der redaktion es gab noch eine
datings ähnlich und dann hat unsere
redaktion einen brief ein intendanten
geschrieben mit der bitte dass man uns
beide vertraglich besser stellt weil es
kann ja nicht angehen ja das ist
rausgekommen wir haben eine
schmallippige
juristische begründung von dr thomas
bellut bekommen das ist alles rechtens
sei das war das erste ich bin natürlich
dann selber auch aktiv geworden bin zum
personalrat gegangen und ich werde nie
diese szene vergessen wie die
personalrätin vor mir saß und ich sagte
zu ihr wirklich verzweifelt ja aber ich
dachte das zdf sei ein
familienfreundliches unternehmen also
eigentlich eine anstalt öffentlichen
rechts und er sagte sie ja france ein
feld aber nur für unsere fest angestellt
so und da muss man jetzt wissen dass das
programm im zdf ohne feste freie
überhaupt nicht stattfinden würde das
ist ein großer teil der mitarbeiter die
diese arbeit leisten und jetzt erzähle
ich kurz was einen mitarbeiter definiert
also ein freier mitarbeiter ist die
junge im zdf keine mitarbeiter wurde mir
mehrfach mitgeteilt aber ich hatte von
anfang an 18 jahre lang meine
lohnsteuerkarte da ich hatte einen ich
war im dienstplan ich war weisungsbefugt
ich hatte einen festen schreibtisch eine
e-mail-affäre einfach nur schön stellt
meinen namen am türschild solange ich
noch ein einziger orte das heißt es sind
die juristischen kategorien dafür dass
ich eine mitarbeiterin war so mit diesen
kategorien bin ich natürlich da jetzt
auch rumgelaufen und das hat sich im
kern nicht nun sind waren schlechter
gestellt ich würde hier gerne einmal
herr bruder heran wenn sie jetzt den
fall hören von frau seibold und dann an
den fall von frau schlesinger denken da
muss man doch fast schon plakativ sagen
die da oben und dann ja das fußvolk
könnte man ja fast zu festen freien
sagen ja so ist es und die beiden fälle
hängen natürlich zusammen weil dieser
schlendrian dieses als ich aus dem luxus
an der spitze ist nur möglich bei einem
bestimmten verteilung der mittel es wird
von unten nach oben umverteilt zugunsten
von oben und nicht andersrum und an der
schleswiger geschichte stellt mich
eigentlich nur eins dieses gerede vom
einzelfall und von der ausnahme jetzt
rückhaltlos untersucht wird ich meine
die haben da seit sieben jahren den
tollsten schlendrian getrieben und es
ist niemand aufgefallen nicht den
stellvertretenden intendanten dem
justiziar den abteilungsleitern
hauptabteilungsleiter ich habe immer ein
problem damit wenn bei einem missstand
eine person herausgestellt wird wissen
sie der führer hat auch nicht von allem
gewusst ich glaube wenn es gewusst hätte
wäre eingeschritten aber haben ja heute
eine sache wer heute hier gesehen dass
auch ganz tolle dokumentation ganze
nicht gelogen auch mit dem rundfunk bei
trier umgesetzt wäre das war ein
eindrucksvolles beispiel für den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk wie
sollte denn der öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk reformiert werden ich weiß es
nicht wissen sie bei fragen oder von
acht milliarden euro passe ich nicht und
das gehört in diesem bereich aber sie
haben natürlich von komplimente leider
kein telefon sogar nein haben wir nicht
ich würde ja auch nicht in anspruch
nehmen auszeiten es werde claudia roth
die weiß ja alles nein es gibt
hervorragende beiträge
die rechtlichen aber allerdings hat sich
meine aufmerksamkeit sehr verengt ich
schaue nur noch arte und 3sat und da
kommen wirklich hervorragende
geschichten also oft mal wenn die wollen
geht es auch und natürlich liefen auf
der hd auch mit der wir liefen in der
ard ja
würde ich mir sogar die sportschau
erreicht
eine überzahlung habe mir sport völlig
egal ist abgesehen von stabhochsprung
das finde ich eine fantastische lieber
selber sie haben das ja knapp 20 jahre
erlebt was wäre ihr plan für den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk wir
reformiert werden kann also ich würde
gerne noch mal drauf eingehen also ich
halte diese debatte was diese
intendanten gehälter angeht eigentlich
für eine sehr populistische
scheindebatte weil es geht um die
strukturen deswegen bin ich auch heute
hier mit diesem thema man muss die
strukturen radikal offenlegen es muss
der öffentlichkeit gegenüber eigentlich
eine art offenbarungseid geleistet
werden zumindest was das zdf angeht ich
kann immer noch vom zdf sprechen wie
hier mitarbeiter behandelt werden es
gibt gerichtsverfahren das am ende steht
immer eine saubere schweige klausel die
natürlich nicht gebrochen werden darf
wegen kommen diese geschichten auch
nicht an die öffentlichkeit ja also
warum ich habe hier eine schweigen
gebrochen sonst die meisten erzählen
einfach nicht darüber und ich glaube es
muss aufhören dass schweigen das sind
wir wieder bei ihrem schuld thema es
sind eigentlich alte mechanismen der
kirche die hier greifen es geht um
schuldgefühle es geht um angst und es
geht um zum schweigen bringen und das
geschieht meistens entweder juristisch
oder eben durch so einen allgemeinen wie
soll ich sagen eine allgemeine meinung
die er zu vertreten ist und ich finde
wir müssen auch auf die letzten zwei
jahre corona berichterstattung zurück
und muss haben sie es schon gemacht in
ihrer sendung was die medien angeht ist
ganz klar aufarbeitung gefragt und auch
eigentlich eine öffentliche entsprechend
ein schöner abhält zum ende der beendung
wesen schon wieder am ende angelangt
nächste woche dienstag sind wir aber
wieder für sie da an werden wieder
leidenschaftlich diskutieren tschüss